personalidades del mundo despiden al
Papa emérito Benedicto 16 Quien murió
hoy a sus 95 años El Vaticano señaló su
avanzada edad Como la causa de su muerte
el cuerpo del pontífice retirado ya será
en la Basílica de San Pedro desde el
próximo lunes y su funeral será el
jueves
en el último día del año Rusia lanzó al
menos 20 misiles contra Ucrania de los
cuales el ejército local asegura haber
derribado más de la mitad se registraron
explosiones en kiev y su cercanías que
hasta el momento dejan un muerto por los
que arremetió contra Vladimir Putin
tildandolo de terrorista
en China ya es 2023 las celebraciones de
fin de año parecen transcurrir Con
normalidad a pesar de la falta de
Claridad de la situación sobre covid de
19 y de las restricciones que imponen
cada vez más países a viajeros
provenientes del gigante asiático
Bienvenidos a la actualización
informativa en France 24 yo soy Daniela
Blandón es un gusto acompañarlos
iniciamos en el Vaticano el papa de
mérito Benedicto 16 murió hoy 31 de
diciembre las campanas de la sede de la
iglesia católica sonaron para despedirlo
tres días antes el portavoz del Vaticano
había anunciado que racinger como se
llamaba Benedicto estaba muy enfermo
debido a su avanzada edad de 95 años su
cuerpo estará en capilar diente en la
Basílica de San Pedro a partir del lunes
y el jueves 5 de enero será el funeral
precedido por una misa que dará el Papa
Francisco nuestra corresponsal en Italia
Natalia Mendoza nos envió el siguiente
reporte
El Vaticano confirmó que el funeral de
Benedicto 16 se llevará a cabo el
próximo jueves 5 de enero la última
voluntad del Papa emérito fue que su
funeral fuera lo más sencillo posible la
ceremonia en la plaza de San Pedro será
presidida por el Papa Francisco se trata
de un ritual inédito ya que es la
primera vez en más de 600 años que un
Papa emérito retirado muere mientras que
ya hay otro papa a cargo gobernando la
Iglesia Católica a partir del próximo
lunes el cuerpo del Papa emérito será
expuesto en la Basílica de San Pedro
para que los fieles que lo deseen puedan
darle un último adiós a Benedicto 16 un
pontífice que será recordado como un
tradicionalista conservador en temas
como el aborto la homosexualidad o la
eutanasia fue un gran teólogo un gran
predicador pero también su papado estuvo
marcado por polémicas por declaraciones
como cuando cuestionó el del
preservativo o escándalos como el
conocido como El batilix la una fuga de
documentos filtrados a la prensa por su
mayordomo personal albatilice muchos le
atribuyeron la causa de su renuncia sin
embargo Benedicto siempre reiteró que
renunció porque sintió que no tenía las
fuerzas físicas para seguir gobernando a
la iglesia católica fuerzas físicas que
definitivamente lo abandonaron este 31
de diciembre cuando murió a las 9 y 34
de la mañana en el Vaticano cambiamos de
información hablamos de la Guerra de
Ucrania porque Rusia atacó nuevamente de
manera masiva de este país el segundo
bombardeo a gran escala en lo que va de
la semana el ejército ucraniano sostiene
que los rusos lanzaron 20 misiles de los
cuales habrían derribado 12 el alcalde
de kiev vitalisco afirmó que al menos
una persona murió y ocho resultaron
heridas por las explosiones en la
capital uno de ellos sería un periodista
japonés según el funcionario también se
reportó la caída de misiles en las
regiones de mico Life y sapolisha el
presidente voleo de mirelsqui aseguró
que los atacantes rusos no serán
perdonados tras el dardos de terroristas
llevaron a cabo tales ataques en semana
santa en navidad en año nuevo se llaman
a sí mismos cristianos están muy
orgullosos de su ortodoxia pero están
siguiendo al [__]
y precisamente en el último día del año
Rusia y Ucrania dijeron haber liberado a
222 soldados en el más reciente
intercambio de prisioneros en el marco
de la Guerra el Ministerio de defensa
ruso informó que la de la liberación de
82 de sus soldados por parte de las
fuerzas ucranianas en tanto el jefe de
gabinete de boludo y mirt selensky
informó que Moscú le había entregado a
140 militares las dos partes en
conflicto han realizado varios
intercambios de prisioneros en los
últimos meses pese a la ruptura de las
conversaciones diplomáticas
y en ese contexto el presidente de Rusia
Vladimir Putin entregó su mensaje de fin
de año y lo hizo durante una visita al
Distrito militar del Sur en rooston en
donde entregó un premio al general
sergey surovikin el jefe de lo que ha
llamado una operación militar especial
en Ucrania antes de su visita en un
mensaje televisado el jefe del crimen
había asegurado que nunca se vería a los
intentos de occidente de destruir a su
país y lo ratificó en su reunión con el
personal militar
Rusia ha sido empujada esa línea o
regala todo o pelea pero mientras haya
personas como ustedes hombres y mujeres
que estén a su lado por supuesto no
podemos regalar nada debemos luchar
debemos seguir adelante
y en otras noticias Corea del Norte
disparó tres misiles al mar hacia el
este de la Península de Corea y así
cierra el 2022 un año en el que más
cohetes ha disparado contra casi un
centenar
el en reacción japona anunció que
comenzará a desarrollar un misil que
podría alcanzar dos mil kilómetros de
distancia y otro misil hipersónico que
podría golpear cualquier parte de Corea
del Norte por otro lado los surcoreanos
respondieron ante los nuevos ensayos
militares de pyongyang
El lanzamiento de misiles balísticos de
Corea del Norte es una grave provocación
que socava la paz y la estabilidad en la
Península y en la comunidad
internacional es una Clara violación de
la resolución del Consejo de Seguridad
de la ONU les instamos a que se detengan
de inmediato
Hablamos ahora de China allí los
ciudadanos intentan que sus
celebraciones de fin de año transcurran
con normalidad a pesar de la falta de
Claridad en las cifras de contagios y
también de muertes por covid 19 así como
las restricciones de varios países hacia
Los viajeros chinos la Organización
Mundial de la Salud le llamó la atención
a Beijing y pidió transparencia mientras
ciudadanos en redes sociales denuncian
lo que Aparentemente podría ser el
colapso de algunos hospitales Samuel
Salgado nos tiene los detalles
sin datos oficiales de contagios y
muertes la Organización Mundial de la
Salud llevó a cabo una reunión de alto
nivel con el gobierno chino para
exigirle transparencia en el intercambio
regular de información sobre el impacto
de la aula de contagios en el país la
OMS enfatizó la importancia del
monitoreo y la publicación oportuna de
datos para ayudar a China y la comunidad
mundial a formular evaluaciones de
riesgo precisas e informar respuestas
efectivas
china ha reportado sólo 13 muertes en lo
corrido de diciembre sin embargo vídeos
aficionados en redes sociales muestran
hospitales abarrotados con largas filas
en las salas de urgencias
y la OMS parece confirmarlo advirtiendo
que el sistema de salud chino podría
estar bajo una fuerte presión el
organismo de la ONU ha reportado más de
20.000 casos diarios una cifra que
contrasta radicalmente con los 5000
diarios que reporta el gobierno chino
en las calles de wuhan ciudad donde
comenzó el brote de covid la normalidad
busca instaurarse y los comerciantes
anhelan recuperarse económicamente luego
el relajamiento de las medidas de la
controvertida política de Cero covid
en los últimos años Incluso en el año en
el que la pandemia estaba en su peor
momento la vida no era tan difícil este
ha sido el peor año posible
en su discurso de fin de año el
presidente defendió el manejo que ha
dado su gobierno a la situación
sanitaria
siguiendo un enfoque científico y
específico hemos adaptado nuestra
respuesta al covid a la luz de la
evolución de la situación para proteger
la vida y la salud de las personas
debido a la falta de Claridad de la
situación en China cada vez son más los
países que endurecen las restricciones
en el ingreso a ciudadanos del gigante
asiático a Corea del Sur Japón Taiwán
Malasia India y Estados Unidos se
sumaron algunos países europeos Italia
España y Francia
y en un repaso por las noticias de
América Latina en Ecuador capturaron al
policía Germán Cáceres
él es el principal sospechoso de haber
asesinado a su esposa María Belén Bernal
la abogada desapareció en la escuela de
formación de oficiales de la policía y
su cuerpo fue encontrado diez días
después ahora el arresto de Cáceres se
dio en Colombia tras una operativo
conjunto
[Aplausos]
y vamos a cerrar por supuesto con la
celebraciones del fin de año porque ya
es 2023 en algunas partes del mundo la
celebraciones comenzaron en Asia
Pacífico el primero en alcanzar las doce
de la noche fue el país insular Kiribati
luego Australia celebró el año nuevo con
sus tradicionales fuegos artificiales
que fueron más de 100.000 y por primera
vez presentó una cascada de arcoiris en
el icónico Harvard Bridge la medianoche
Ya pasó también en Nueva Zelanda en las
coreas en Japón y en China
con estas imágenes despedimos esta
emisión en France 24 pero los invitamos
a que continúen con nosotros en France
24 y también en France 24.1
[Música]